-Thank you so much
for coming here in person.
-It's so fun to be here.
It's so nice to see you, pally.
-It's so nice
to see your face, buddy.
Thank you.
We talked during the quarantine,
obviously, and you helped me out
with some bits.
You sent me a couple photos
from quarantine
that I wanted to show.
-Mm-hmm.
-This first one here,
I just wanted --
Who is this,
and what exactly is going --
-This who I am now, Jimmy.
-Is that the new you?
-This is the new me.
This is actually a picture of --
That outfit is from
the "Tonight Show" aunties bit
that we did.
-I love that.
-I was at home wearing it
that day
because I was very excited,
because that is the first car
I have ever owned in my life.
-What?
-I got my first car
during quarantine.
-Wow!
-Thank you.
-Wait. This is --
This is major.
You never bought a car.
-Yeah, 'cause I'm a big, like,
subway, bus...bitch.
And --
[ Laughter ]
I'm such a bitch.
Trolley...
And so, yeah,
I never used to drive.
I always had a license
that I never used,
and then, during quarantine,
when I didn't like --
The subway wasn't open.
I was just, like,
"I want to have some agency,"
and so I wanted to go
look for cars,
and my husband was like,
"Maybe get, like, a Mini Cooper
or, like, a fun car
or, like, a Jeep or a BMW,"
and I was like, "No.
I know what I want."
And it's a white
Subaru Forester.
And, um --
-I've never even heard
of a Subaru Forester.
-It's so basic.
I'm like, "Mwah, mwah, mwah!
It's basic."
-Oh, my God!
-And my -- It's funny,
'cause Alice is 15 now.
My older daughter's 15,
and she --
-Wow. Is she 15?
-I think she's looking
at that car, knowing, like,
that's the car she's gonna learn
to drive on, and she's like...
She was really pushing for,
like, a cuter, cooler car,
and I was like,
"No, I want a car
that looks like
a medical sneaker."
[ Laughter ]
"It's so safe.
It looks like
Judah Friedlander's
frickin' sneakers.
And she's like, "But, Mom,
that's such a Karen car."
And I was like,
"I'm naming her Karen,"
and now I'm always, like,
"Should we take Karen
to the store?"
and no one in the family
finds it humorous
that I named the car.
-Did you --
Did you take Karen
and get out of the city at all
during quarantine?
-Yeah, we did.
After about...
'Cause we were in the city
in the beginning,
'cause I remember I was talking
to you in the beginning,
and you were like, "Do you
want to come to our house?"
Like, you were concerned for me
that we were just in the
apartment for a couple months.
But, like, so many New Yorkers,
my kids, at a certain point,
hadn't been outside
in six or eight weeks.
They were becoming like the
children in the "Secret Garden."
Like, "May I have some...?"
-"Is that sunlight, Mum?"
-"I would like
to meet the wind."
[ Laughter ]
And so...
-"No, you can't meet the wind,
not today."
"Not today."
So, after, like,
a couple months, we did --
we were fortunate enough --
we rented a house
outside the city.
And the first time we got to
this place, where it had a yard
and we could go outside --
I was, like,
outside in the morning with my
coffee without a whole protocol
in my own little yard,
and the first morning
that we were there,
I was standing outside,
and we were looking down --
You can see the Hudson River
from where we are.
It's so pretty.
And I heard -- I'm standing
there with my coffee,
and I just hear
something going...
"Help! Help!"
And it -- I was like,
"Is that a 'help' or a bird?"
'Cause I've been in my house
for two months, right?
So I'm like, "Is that
a person saying 'help'?"
So, I went
and got my older daughter,
and I was like, "Come out here,
come out here."
And we're standing outside --
again, like, mole people.
Haven't been outside.
-Yeah.
-Looking down at the river,
and we're waiting,
and, like, a couple minutes go
by, and then we hear it again.
It was like, "Help! Help!"
So then I called Jeff out.
Like, he's from the country.
He grew up in the country.
He'll know if this is a bird.
'Cause I'm thinking, like,
"We're gonna freak out
about this and he's gonna be
like, 'Hey, you weirdo.
It's a bird.'"
-Yes.
-So, he comes out.
We're all standing out there.
We hear it again --
"Help!"
So, we called the cops.
We're like, "What do we do?"
We called the cops.
Our first day out of the house,
we're, like, calling the cops at
the height of the pandemic.
Cop comes, he listens.
And, of course, he's like,
"Well, hello!"
Like, he's got a strong voice.
'Cause I've just been like,
"Everybody okay?"
Like, I can't --
-Yeah, sure.
And then we hear it again,
"Help!"
So, the cops take off.
And then, we found out, like,
a couple hours later
that it was a guy
who flipped a kayak
in the Hudson...
-Are you --
-...and was floating north
in the Hudson and just, like,
no oar and just was flo--
And they found him
like a mile north.
-What is going --
Tina, you saved a man's life!
-I saved a man's life!
-Oh, my gosh!
Wait. What?!
-He doesn't know
that it was us, but...
-I can't believe
that happened to you.
-Isn't that crazy?
Also, never kayak!
Why?
-Oh, my gosh.
-Never kayak!
-"Never kayak."
-On the Hudson?
That's not, like, a stream.
It's like a rat toilet.
Why are you kayaking the Hudson?
-Oh, my God.
That's the lesson learned.
I love that, of all people,
it would happen to you.
-Day one.
-Day one, come out with
your coffee and you hear
someone screaming for help.
[ Both laugh ]
Oh, my gosh.
That is bizarre.
You saved a man's life.
This is great.
-That's it.
-Well, let's talk about --
it's a good segue into "Soul."
-Yes.
About the value of life.
-The value of life.
Gosh, I loved it.
Watched it over the weekend
with the kids.
You're phenomenal in this.
-Aww, thank you.
It's so beautiful.
It's really a piece of art.
I mean, don't you think?
I mean, it's like --
You have the --
the beauty of the way New York
is rendered,
which I've never seen
an animation of New York
rendered so realistically
and beautifully.
And then, also, this whole other
ethereal world
of The Great Before
and The Great Beyond.
-Yeah.
-So, yeah, it's the story of --
"Soul" is the story of
a guy named Joe Gardner
who is a middle-school
band teacher whose real goal
is to be a professional
jazz musician,
and he's kind of, like,
hung up on
making this happen for himself.
And then, something happens to
him that I won't give away,
and he is kind of
knocked out of his body,
and his soul goes up to
a place called The Great Before,
which is where souls come from.
And he's trying
to get back to Earth and --
And he's just gotten
his big break.
He's trying
to get back to Earth.
And he meets my character there,
which is a little --
unctuous little soul named 22.
-22, man.
-Who has never been convinced
to go down into Earth
and get into a body.
She's had all these mentors
try to explain to her,
like, why it would be great
to live on Earth,
and she's like, "I don't know.
Sounds painful.
It sounds scary.
I'm gonna pass."
She just wants to skip
the whole thing.
-Yeah.
She doesn't get Earth.
She doesn't quite understand.
"I didn't really get it."
But whatever.
-Yeah. So -- Yeah.
So, they have --
You know, it's sort of a buddy
comedy between the two of them,
and she's trying -- She's like,
"You can take my spot."
Like, "We'll help you
get back to Earth.
It's your body.
You can have it."
-It's phenomenal.
I don't want to tell anyone
what happens in the film
'cause it's just worth watching.
And it's beautiful the way it
unfolds, and you get to see it.
But do you want
to set up this clip at all?
-Oh, yeah!
So, this clip, I think, is --
So, Jamie's character, Joe,
is in The Great Before
with me, where all souls get
their personality traits
and what makes them unique.
And I take him to this place
called The Hall of Everything,
which is a place where
new souls can try everything
on Earth -- every job,
every hobby, every occup--
Everything.
-"Maybe I like music.
Maybe I like cooking."
-Yeah, to see what sparks
life in them.
And so, this is me
taking him around there.
-Yeah. Here we go.
Let's take a look.
-Where do you want to start?
-Come on.
Croissants, cakes?
Baking could be your spark.
-Yeah!
But, um, I don't get it.
-Just smell it.
-Can't, and neither can you.
-What?
You're right.
I can't smell.
We can't --
We can't taste, either?
-All that stuff is in your body.
-No smell, no taste --
-Or touch.
See?
♪♪
-Okay! I get it.
Moving on.
-[ Laughs ]
Tina Fey, everybody!
"Soul" premieres Christmas Day
on Disney+.